kim est une jeune femme qui quétier
consommatrice de ce genre de produit qui
je le rappelle est légale si on est
majeur il
n'est pas majeur on pourrait tout à fait
honnête oui enfin aux gens une loi vient
de passer encore quelques temps mais mes
propos les mineurs qui encadrent
maintenant l'utilisation vous étiez
jeudi vous étiez parce que vous vous
êtes arrêté le jour où une de vos amis
va frôler la mort à cause de ces de ce
produit et depuis elle se vous vous
battez contre contre l'utilisation de
ces produits vous preniez s'est produit
c'est quoi c'était à usage récréatif
alors c'était je sortais un comme tous
les jeunes locaux vides après quand là
quand les boîtes les bars ils ont
réouvert on est tous on est tous un peu
ressorti et c'est vraiment là où c'est
devenu la mode enfin moi j'avais jamais
entendu parler de ça avant et donc je
sortais avec mes copains et en fait
c'était en vente complètement libre en
boîte mais voilà toutes les bretons il
faut expliquer comment est ce que parce
que moi quand on a dix pros toxiques moi
j'ai pensé vous savez les ballons qu'on
respire et en fait j'ai fait une erreur
c'est cepsum l'hélium salle de bal
encore espoir lorsque nous y sommes mais
il ya aussi les ballons en tout cas les
ballons champions sommes
le produit se consomme avec des ballons
donc en fait ils gonflent un ballon avec
six viols et en fait le ballon tu
souffres dedans tu l'as pierre tueurs
souffler c'est comme ça en fait que tu
ta l'effet de défonce en fait ça a l'air
complètement anodin parce qu'on se dit
pas on s'amuse c'est légal on ne risque
rien et pourtant donc dit évidemment
très facile d'en trouver
de nuit comme ça
c'est pour une partie beaucoup plus
accessible que des cigares à bientôt moi
j'ai tant gêné a chip cet été c'était
dans la rue ces listes tellement normal
et on m'a demandé plus ma qualité pour
des cigarettes que pour des ballons
racontez-moi alors ce jour alors donc
vous me dites en gros dés qu'on vend dès
qu'on allait en soirée avec les amis ben
on faisait ce truc là sans se douter à
quel point ça pouvait être dangereux
pouvez vous aviez quand même bah en fait
c'était un peu c'était compliqué de se
positionner parce que d'un côté on
entendait des histoires mais voilà comme
pas entendre des histoires sur tout et
n'importe quoi on voyait des reportages
de personnes qui avaient eu des
séquelles mais qu'ils étaient des
personnes qui en consommaient plus de 3
par jour dont vous vous dites c'est pas
moi c'est pas nous
c'est qu'on gagne et qui avait fait un
reportage d'une jeune femme qui avait
complètement addict qui vraiment cessé
de vivre alors justement il ya ce jour
là où vous allez décider d'arrêter d'en
prendre parce que vous assistez à une
sciatique dans l'incroyable un accident
une amie en prend voilà raconte que
s'est il passé alors pas encore une fois
ma bande d'amis on est tous ensemble et
c'est mon ami décide d'en prendre on en
langues et tous ensemble à rendre tout
ça est en fait bas au moment où elle en
a pris elle a fait une mauvaise chute
liée au fait qu'en fait son cerveau a
manqué d'oxygène est en fait moi je n'ai
pas pensé une seconde que c'était
forcément lié au ballon je me suis pas
dit que ça allait être grave au final
après il ya eu des complications qui ont
fait que bas à cause de ce fameux ballon
elle a eu des halles elle a été
hospitalisée extérieur parce qu'en fait
elle a fait une chute qui aurait pu
aurait été largement évité à cause de
grève si jamais elle avait pas pris le
ballon et on verra des comptes sur le
moment quand que bah voilà vous êtes
tous dans une euphorie ce que vous êtes
tous en train d'en prendre donc est ce
que vous vous étiez lucide à ce moment
là lors les dés pour vous rendre compte
qu'il se passait quelque chose parce que
l état à ce moment là entre la vie et la
mort alors voilà et alors savoir que ce
qui se passe ce qui est vrai c'est qu'on
est dans un endroit unique ouvert parce
que on n'était pas là dans un
appartement on n'était pas tous
complètement défoncé avec des gens
autour qui était complètement lucide
peut-être un peu alcoolisé mais qui je
pense avait aussi le qui ont vu la
possibilité de l'aider et en fait c'est
vrai que à ce moment là nous on était on
se rendait pas forcément compte de la
gravité de la chose parce que encore une
fois c'est une chute on s'est dit bon
bah la tribu chez quoi on se dit pas on
ne dit pas on ne dit pas assez grave et
en fait c'était c'était vraiment quelque
chose qu'on ne prenait pas au sérieux
parce que ça vous servant tellement
librement qu'on se dit pas bon c'est
quelque chose de grave c'est quelque
chose de dangereux vraiment vraiment
pour pour nous et en fait c'est vrai que
les faits il est tellement le ce père
c'est que c'est un effet qui dure 30
secondes